Transcriber: Sana Fares
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
‫بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم .‬
‫يقول الفيلسوف الفرنسي ديكارت
ليس المهم أن‬
‫تمتلك عقلا جيدا ،
المهم أن تستخدمه جيدا .‬
المؤكد أن الغالبية العظمى
من‬‫ الناس
لديهم قدرات عقلية عالية ،
بل ومذهلة‬‫ جدا
‫دعوني في عجالة فقط
أسلط الضوء على القدرات‬
‫الدماغية الموجودة لديكم .‬
‫دماغك
يحتوي على ألف مليار خلية دماغية .‬
‫الخلايا الدماغية هذي إما أن تكون عصبية‬
‫أو تكون خلايا مساعدة لها .‬
‫كم عدد الخلايا العصبية الموجودة عندك‬
‫ستة وثمانين مليار خلية عصبية
رقم مدهش‬
‫القشرة الدماغية لوحدها يوجد فيها‬
‫ستة عشر مليار خلية عصبية .‬
‫أنا لن أتكلم عن الستة وثمانين‬
‫مليار خلية عصبية .‬
‫أكلمك عن خلية عصبية فقط واحدة .‬
‫الخلية العصبية الواحدة اللي انت عندك‬
‫منها ستة وثمانين مليار .‬
‫الخلية الوحدة هي أعقد من أعقد جهاز‬
‫ذكي ابتكره البشر إلى هذا اليوم .‬
‫فيها كم هائل من المركبات الكيميائية‬
‫والكهربائية .‬
‫وفيها نظام مجهري دقيق مذهل!
يساعدك‬‫ في فك رموز
المعلومات ومعالجتها .‬
‫يعني كم عندك جهاز ذكي موجود في دماغك يا‬
‫راجل انت تحاسب على على جهازك ، هذا لا‬
‫يسقط منك عجلات كسر الشاشة إنكه يوجد‬
‫هنا كم جهاز ذكي موجود في دماغك .‬
‫الأمر مذهل جدا .‬
‫ليس هذا فحسب .‬
‫هذه الخلايا العصبية تتعانق .‬
‫كل خلية عصبية
تعانق الخلية العصبية الأخرى‬
‫هذا العناق العجيب يولد وصلات‬
‫عصبية مذهلة جدا .‬
‫يصفها تشارلز تيرنر هذا الرائد
الفسيولوجيا‬‫ العصبية
ماذا يقول اسمع بالله الكلام‬
‫الجميل الذي يقوله ، يقول وهو يصف هذا‬
‫العناق بين الخلايا العصبية .‬
‫يقول كما لو أن مجرة درب التبانة‬
‫دخلت في حفل فضائي راقص .‬
‫هذا خلق الله .‬
‫هذه عظمة رب العالمين .‬
‫ابداع هذا كله في دماغك .‬
‫طيب اذا زادت التشابكات العصبية
هذه تستفيد‬
‫تزيد درجة الذكاء ،
وإذا زادت درجة ذكائك‬
‫زادت قدرتك على التعلم والتذكر والاسترجاع‬
‫والتحليل والاستنتاج .‬
‫طيب هذه القدرات الهائلة الموجودة عندك‬
‫تجعلنا نصل الى استنتاج واضح .‬
‫ولا يقبل أبدا للنقاش .‬
‫إن كل المشاكل التي يعانون منها في الحفظ‬
‫في الذاكرة ،
في التعلم في أي قدرات
لا ‫علاقة لها مطلقا بسعة المخ ،
ما لها علاقة‬‫ بسعة المخ
لها علاقة بسوء إدارة هذه السعة .‬
‫ولذلك أنا أطلب منك ان تستخدم‬
‫دماغك بفعالية .‬
‫أنت لديك قدرات دماغية عالية .‬
‫المطلوب منك شو انك تستخدم‬
‫هذه القدرات بفعالية .‬
‫طيب السؤال كيف ؟ كيف؟
أنا لا أزعم أبدا‬
‫أنني في ثمانية عشر دقيقة
سأقول لك كل شيء
‫لكن سأسلط الضوء على نقاط
في غاية الأهمية .‬
‫أول نقطة .‬
‫صلوا على النبي زيد النبي صلى
الدماغ ما‬‫يقدر يتعلم إلا لما يعرف
المعنى والأهمية .‬
‫لا يمكن أن تتعلم
الا ان لو دماغك يعرف معنى‬
‫ما يتعلم وأهمية ما ما يتعلم
الان ‫ممكن تأخذ طالب في قسم الرياضيات
وتقول‬
‫حبيبي تعال هذه دالة وبغض كامل أهلية من‬
‫اثنين الى خمسة تفضل كامل الدال‬
‫يطلع لك التكامل صح .‬
‫لكن عندما تسأل ما معنى التكامل لا يجيبك‬
‫تسأل ما أهمية التكامل ؟ لا يجيبك الدماغ‬
‫لا يعمل إذا كانت الفجوة هذه موجودة .‬
‫إذا كانت إذا كان الفاقد هذا موجود‬
‫دماغك لا يشتغل كويس .‬
‫ما السبب في الكلام هذا ؟ أعطيك‬
‫دليل لا يقبل النقاش أيضا .‬
‫أي طفل في الدنيا إن ولد ؟
إن ولد آدم يعني‬
‫أنت كلكم لما ولدت بمواصفات نيش مواصفات‬
‫علماء من جد والله .‬
‫كل واحد منكم ولد، ولد بمواصفات عالم
‫شوف الطفل الذي يسأل يقول
لك شو هذا يا بابا .‬
‫طيب شو هذا طيب ليش سويت كذا أكثر سؤالين‬
‫يسألها ايش هذا ؟ وليش هذا ؟‬
‫ليش؟ هو في رحلة البحث عن المعنى والأهمية
‫من وهو نازل يبحث عن المعنى والأهمية ،
ولذلك‬
‫أنت لا تحرم دماغك عندما تقرأ
أي شيء
اسأل‬‫ نفسك ما معناه وما
وما أهميته ؟
هذه نقطة‬
‫اثنين .‬
‫وانت تذاكر أو تتعلم استثر‬
‫كلا فلقتي الدماغ .‬
‫روجر سبير حصل على جائزة نوبل .‬
‫عندما اكتشف شو؟ عندما اكتشف أن الدماغ‬
‫عبارة عن فلقتين يمنى ولا يسرى
الفلقة ‫اليسرى مسؤولة عن
شو عن الكلمات والألفاظ‬
‫والأعداد والأرقام والحسابات والتحليل‬
‫والمنطق والتسلسل الخطي .‬
‫أما الفلقة اليمنى فهي مسؤولة عن الإبداع‬
‫والخيال والإدراك المكاني والصور الكلية‬
‫والألوان والعواطف والمشاعر والإيقاعات .‬
‫طيب أنا الآن أتعلم ، كيف أتعلم
‫واستثمر كلا فلقتي الدماغ؟
‫عندما أقرأ معلومات معينة حولها‬
‫إلى ايش ؟ إلى صور .‬
‫عندما أقرأ نظرية أو تعميم معين
اخلي مصحوب‬
‫برسوم بيانية تسهل علي فهم هذه النظرية‬
‫عندما تقع على نص أدبي أبيات شعر مثلا‬
‫جعلها مترافقة بشو بالإيقاع
‫أنا أعطيك مثال على شان أسليك شويه .‬
‫لو انت وقعت عينك على نص
بنيتي عصفورة شادية‬
تلعب في ظل الصبا ، لاهية إذا تطلعت‬
‫إلى وجهها رأيت أمي مرة ثانية .‬
‫طيب دعني استثير كلا فلقتي الدماغ عندك
‫وأقول بنيتي عصفورة شادية
تلعب في ظل ‫الصبا لاهية
إذا تطلعت إلى وجهها
رأيت‬‫ أمي مرة ثانية رأيت
أمي مرة ثانية .‬
‫الآن أنا أتعلم وأستثير‬
‫كلا فلقتي الدماغ .‬
‫في الحالة هذه دماغك شو يسوي‬؟
‫يتعلم ويستمتع كمان .‬
‫نقطة ثلاثة دماغك متفرد ،
كل دماغ موجود هنا‬
‫
متفرد له رموز خاصة وله روابط خاصة .‬
‫طيب نحن لدينا نفس الأجهزة الدماغية ، لكن‬
‫رغم هذا نحن مختلفين ، طب لماذا مختلفين‬
‫لأن مدخلات الحسية مختلفة ،
الشيء اللي بشوفو أنا‬
‫غير الشيء الذي أنت تشوفه
أهل جدة هنا
ماذا ‫يشاهدون؟
يشاهدون البحر والواجهة البحرية .‬
‫أهل الجنوب شو يشوفو؟ الجبال‬
‫والأشجار وجداول الماء .‬
‫أهل الوسطى وهل الشمال يشوفوا
يشوفوا الرمال‬‫ والتكوينات الصخرية ،
لذلك إذا‬
‫اختلفت المدخلات الحسية ستختلف المعالجات‬
‫وبالتالي هذا الذي يخليني مختلف عنك .‬
‫طيب على شان يتعلم دماغك بشكل فعال عليك
أن‬‫ تضفي طابعك الخاص على المعلومات
التي ‫تقرأها .‬
‫يعني أي معلومة تقرأها أضفي عليها‬
‫طابع ماذا؟ طابعك الخاص .‬
‫طيب أنا أعطيك مثال بسيط
لعبد الله القرني
لما أضفى طابع الخاص
على ايش على معلومة‬ معينة
أعطيك تعريف .‬
‫التعريف هذا ما يقول .‬
التعريف
‫تعريف التفكير التفكير شوهو سلسلة من‬
‫النشاطات العقلية التي يقوم بها الدماغ .‬
‫انظر الصورة التي هنا شو موجود موجود‬
‫دماغ مربوط بشو مربوط بسلسلة .‬
‫ما يعني هذا ؟
هذة شفرة رابط
سلسلة من‬‫ النشاطات العقلية التي يقوم
بها من؟ الدماغ .‬
‫طيب متى؟ عندما يتعرض لمجموعة من المثيرات‬
‫أنا شفرتها كيف ؟
شايفين ميم واحد
ميم ‫اثنين ميم ثلاثة ميم أربعة مثيرات
يتم استقبال‬‫ هذه المثيرات
عن طريق ماذا
عن‬‫ طريق الحواس الخمسة ؟
شوف‬
‫الحواس الخمس الموجودة .‬
‫وبالتالي تتم المعالجة
للوصول الى حل مشكلة‬‫ أو تحقيق هدف
أو اصدار حكم أو إتخاذ قرار
‬‫أنا شو سويت في التعريف
شفرته. أعطيته طابعي الخاص
‫أنا متأكد لو أعطي التعريف لأي واحد
أو وحدة‬‫ في القاعة
يعطيها شفرة مختلفة ،
لماذا‬
‫تعطيها شفرة مختلفة لأن دماغك متفرد ؟
ولذلك‬‫ يضفي طابعة الخاص على
المعلومات التي‬‫ تقرأها
‫صلى النبي زيد النبي صلى .‬
‫دعت دماغك يحلق ويتخيل شوف أنا أقول لك .‬
‫خذ هذه النقطة وضعها دائما أمامك نحن‬
‫أدمغتنا ، لماذا لا تعمل بفعالية لأن نحن‬
‫قتلنا الروتين .‬
‫نفس الأشياء التي نتعرض لها اليوم هي التي‬
‫سنتعرض لها ، متى غدا ؟ أعطيك مثال .‬
‫يومنا .‬
‫زي أمسنا ، الواحد شو يسوي يروح‬
‫يتمشى في نفس المكان .‬
‫يروح من المكان يتعشى في
نفس المطعم كل أسبوع
لما تعطيه القائمة
يطلب من القائمة أكل معين .‬
‫يجلس مع أناس معينين يسمع نفس السوالف
كل‬‫ ليلة نفس السوالف من نفس الأشخاص
ويقرأ في‬
‫تخصص ويتمحور حوله ايش؟ حول تخصصه
كيف يعمل‬‫ دماغك انت كل يوم تعطيه مثيرات
نفس المثيرات
مايشتغل!
‫ولذلك لذاتي بغاء يعمل بفعالية‬
‫، اقرأ في تخصص مختلف .‬
‫هذا واحد اثنين أجلس مع ناس‬
‫من اهتمامات ماذا مختلفة ؟‬
‫سافر إلى أماكن مختلفة .‬
‫طيب خليني اخلي دماغك يحلق شوية.ممكن؟
أنا طلبت منهم الكرسي هذا لأجلس ،
أنا أتكلم‬‫ لكم قصة وأسمع دماغك
مجموعة من المثيرات هو‬
‫ما هو متعود يسمعها عشان أخلي يحلق ويتخيل
‫خليكم معاية بس. هذا محمد
كان نايم بين والديه ،‬
‫وفي منتصف الليل ذهب إلى النافذة وفتح .‬
‫فوجد القمر مكتملا ومنظره
‫رائع جدا على قمة الجبل .‬
‫تسلل من البيت وخرج وأخذ يصعد الجبل
ويصعد‬
‫ويصعد ويصعد ويصعد حتى بلغ قمة الجبل .‬
‫أراد أن يلمس القمر ولكنه وجد القمر .‬
‫قد ابتعد كثيرا فصنع سلما طويلا
‫باستخدام الفأس والأشجار .‬
‫وضع السلم على قمة الجبل والطرف الآخر
على ماذا؟ على سطح القمر
ثم أخذ يصعد ويصعد ويصعد‬
‫ويصعد ويصعد حتى بلغ سطح القمر .‬
‫وعندما وصل هناك هبت
رياح قوية فسقط السلم
‫وعرف محمد أنه سيقضي بقية‬
‫حياته على سطح القمر .‬
‫إلا أنه عندما واصل السير وجد مدينة ألعاب‬
‫ضخمة ويحرسها رجال فضائيين .‬
‫طلب منهم الدخول فى أدخلوه‬
‫مجانا بدون مقابل .‬
‫أنتم دخلتم بمقابل ما معقول تسمعون بلاش .‬
‫دخل والمفاجأة كانت أنه
وجد جميع الموجودين‬
‫في المدينة هم أصدقاؤه في القرية ، فسألهم‬
‫كيف صعدت إلى هنا ؟ قالوا ألا تعلم عندما‬
‫يكتمل القمر تنزل المركبة الفضائية
إلى قمة‬ الجبل
‫ويصعد بنا آباؤنا الى قمة الجبل
نمطي صهوة‬‫ هذه المركبة
ونذهب الى القمر ونقضي ليلة‬
‫رائعة ثم نعود بعدها عاد معهم على‬
‫متن هذه المركبة نزل من الجبل .‬
‫دخل البيت ثم ذهب لينام بين والديه .‬
‫الآن بسألك سؤال
‫بأمانة كنت مستمتع
أو لا
‫في ناس قالو لأ ديخربوها علي
‫يوجد الآن هذا الشيء الخيالي .‬
‫الدماغ هذا يحبه جدا ،
ولذلك عود دماغك على‬
‫على الخروج دائما عن ماذا عن المألوف ؟‬
‫اسمع أشياء شاهد أفلام خيال علمي
على شان‬
‫الدماغ يرى مثيرات جديدة وبالتالي معالجة‬
‫عقلية جديدة .‬
‫آخر نقطة سأختم فيها في دقيقتين فقط .‬
‫الدماغ يحب التحدي .‬
‫ما اقصد التحديات المصحوبة‬
‫بدرجة عالية من القلق .‬
‫لا. تحديات مصحوبة بنسبة معينة من ماذا‬
‫؟
من القلق ولازم تحط في بالك .‬
انتبه
أنا رح ‫أعطيك هدية لا تقدر بثمن
احفظها جيدا!
‫المشكلة نعمة وليست نقمة .‬
‫طلاب الدراسات العليا
الماجستير والدكتوراه‬
‫لما يلاقي واحد منهم مشكلة يطير فرحا
ويقول ‫وجدتها وجدتها وجدتها
أنت لازم
تتعامل مع‬‫ المشكلات من اليوم وطالع
منها نعمة وليست‬‫ نقمة ،
أي مشكلة تقابلك اعتبرها تحدي ،
أبسط‬‫ شيء في الدنيا
أبسط شيء في الدنيا .‬
انظر البراد
‫هذا البراد الذي قدامك الذي تشرب في هذا‬
‫في مشكلتين
في مشكلة الثقل ومشكلة الحرارة .‬
‫طيب لما أنت تعتبر المشكلة مشكلتك
وتعمل‬
‫عقلك فيها يستمتع عقلك بالتحدي فينتج مثل‬
‫هذا ما لك عملنا حوامل وأذنين
‫تخلصنا من مشكلة الثقل ومشكلة‬
‫ماذا ؟ ومشكلة الحرارة .‬
‫اعتبر أي مشكلة تحدي وأعمل دماغك فيها
تذكر ‫ليس المهم أن تمتلك عقلا جيدا .‬
‫المهم أن تستخدمه جيدا .‬
‫يعن الله القرني كان سعيدا جدا بلقائكم .‬
(تصفيق)
‫وسيكون .‬
‫الله يكرمك على راسي حبيبي
الله يسعدك وسأكون‬
‫والله اسعد عندما أراكم مرة اخرى‬
‫الى ذلك الحين نترككم في
حفظ الله ورعايته .‬
‫والسلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته .‬